Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I want to start this video with a
new feature called the mystery language.
I'm going to play a language for you
that you may have not heard before,
and at the end of the video I will let
you know what this language is.
So check it out
a sas,
then the gus and Alisa Fallon trying to
date must watch away.
Mislead it's live.
Okay.
Stay tuned until the end of the video
and I will tell you what language you
just heard.
Okay.
Onto our main topic.
What country has the most languages
spoken?
What country is the most linguistically
diverse?
Many of us come from countries where
there may just be one or two main
languages and maybe some other regional
minority languages too,
but there are some countries in the
world where the amount of linguistic
variation is just mindblowing.
The country with the most languages
spoken is Papa New Guinea with at least
820 different languages spoken.
Imagined that upload.
New Guinea is a very rural country where
88 percent of the people live in rural
areas now compare that to 10 percent of
the people in the United Kingdom living
in rural areas for 19 point three
percent of the American population
living in rural areas.
Papa New Guinea is very rural indeed and
because of Papa New Guinea is rugged
terrain and it's deep valleys,
there's a limited amount of
communication between all of those
isolated rural community.
That's why they're remained such an
amazing amount of linguistic variety
today without any particular languages
sort of growing in influence and
dominating the others.
You imagined that your village speaks
one language and the neighboring village
just a few kilometers away,
speaks an entirely different language.
That's sometimes the case in top one new
Guinea,
and I'm not even talking about different
dialects of the same language,
although that happens too.
I'm talking about completely different
languages.
In certain cases,
the languages of New Guinea fall into
three categories.
The first one is the Austronesian
languages,
which arrived in Papa New Guinea about
3,500
years ago.
Then there are the top one languages
which predate the Austronesian languages
in Buffalo,
New Guinea,
and then there are the foreign languages
and creole languages that serve as
Lingua Franca.
The term pop one language simply refers
to languages that predate the
Austronesian languages,
languages that are indigenous to pop one
new beginnings.
It does not mean that they are a single
language family.
There are actually several dozen
different language families amongst the
pop one languages.
Some of those language families have no
connection to each other and there are
some language isolates.
That means that there are individual
languages that have no known connection
to any other languages in the world.
Most pop one languages are spoken by
only a few hundred to a few thousand
people.
There are a few that are spoken by over
100,000
people.
There are three official languages in
Papua New Guinea.
The first one is English,
the second is talk piece in,
and the third one is he.
The to the most widely spoken is top in.
It is an English creole language which
arose during the colonial period,
top face and is now used as a Lingua
Franca,
which is very important in a country
with so many different languages and it
is also now spoken as a native language
by many people took in is less widely
spoken in the southern region of couple.
We're a different language,
often functions as the Lingua Franca,
and that is key.
The motu two is a simplified creole,
have another Austronesian language
called multi.
Its use has been declining in recent
times in favor of English and talk
English is only spoken by one to two
percent of the population,
but it is widely used in business and it
is supposedly the language of education,
but if English is the language of
education and only one to two percent of
the people speak it,
then that sounds like a pretty dodgy
education system.
To me.
The second most linguistically diverse
country in the world is Indonesia,
which lives right next to Poplin.
In fact,
half of the island of New Guinea lies
inside Indonesia.
About 740 languages are spoken in
Indonesia,
but there was only one official language
and Lingua Franca and that is Bahasa
Indonesia or Indonesian.
Number three is Nigeria with 516
languages spoken,
but English is used as a Lingua Franca,
especially in the urban areas.
I guess they need English to communicate
with all those thieving oil companies.
Number four is India with 427 languages.
The main Lingua Franca is our Hindi as
well as English,
which was left behind by the British
colonizers in exchange for a massively
huge amounts of India's resources,
and number five is the USA,
which has 311 languages.
Now,
that may sound surprising because we
think of the USA as an English speaking
country,
but remember that there are over a
hundred indigenous languages in the USA
even though many of them have a very
limited number of speakers these days.
There are also a couple of hundred
different languages spoken by immigrants
to the USA.
It may be hard to wrap your head around
that huge degree of linguistic
diversity,
especially if you are interested in one
of those countries and you want to learn
a language to communicate with the
people there,
but luckily those countries all have one
or more Lingua Franca,
which can help you communicate with a
much larger proportion of the population
from various different linguistic
communities.
Thank you for watching the line focus
channel.
Be sure to check out my social media
links,
facebook,
twitter,
instagram,
and Google plus,
and also check out the lang focus.com
blog as well.
The mystery language from the beginning
of the video was the Malagasy language
from Madagascar.
For more information on the Malagasy
language,
quick here and visit the Lang focus
website.
Thanks again for watching.
Have a nice.
Yes.